l'histoire chronologiquement on entend
des bruissements dans les retours de
noeux des micros c'est à dire on capte
voilà et on entend des trucs en lien
avec des histoires de papaye bon et puis
partage papaye on comprend pas très bien
et en écoutant un peu plus on se dit
tiens il ya quelque chose et à ce moment
là julien magne quel producteur du
programme et qui étaient sur place va
avoir les aventuriers et là en pesant
détention theora va immédiatement avoué
que en effet il a triché et et qu' il
s'est fait livrer de la nourriture et
qu'il a partagés
alors j'avoue qu'on s'attendait pas eu
une telle information on a été
extrêmement surpris à ce moment là
comment ça se passe bien c'est quand
même important c'est là une première
dans koh lanta
donc il faut se rappeler qu'on est en
polynésie qui à 12 heures de décalage
ans et c'est là où habite et où il ya la
famille tôt oui alors comme vous le
savez theora et polynésiens on était
d'ailleurs sur des îles qu'il connaît
bien il en a déjà parlé un certain et
raiatea et on avait fait juste moins
ultra attention parce qu'on savait qu'il
pouvait y avoir un risque on lui avait
parlé avant l'émission on avait fait
attention de prendre par exemple les
pilotes des bateaux que ça ne soit pas
des pilotes de lille deux fois qu'ils
connaissent et
laura et cetera qui est pas bien et donc
à ce moment-là on dit attendez on va
faire une enquête et c'est tout parce
qu'on comprend pas très bien en fin de
compte tout ce qui se passe c'est tout
et la voilà
au bout de quatre jours dans kate on
prend la décision en sachant qu'on prend
la décision tf1 denis évidemment
julia man qui est sur place et moi
d'exclure no name à
gaza a été difficile comme décision ces
dernières décisions des c'était la seule
décision pouviez prendre non parce que
là c'est une grosse crise financière
c'est vraiment le code d'honneur de koh
lanta alors il faut quand même le dire
et je sais pas parce qu'on l'a
sanctionné et d'ailleurs ils
s'attendaient à la sanction enfin à une
sanction d'avion et d'ailleurs c'est lui
oui la vie cette saison et en parlera
mieux que moi a été extrêmement
difficile
enfin c'est pas toi tu peux laisser là
dit il a dit que c'était la saison la
plus difficile qu'il ait fait de koh
lanta vichy punk est sûre vous posez
encore avec savent qu'il ya plein de
questions qu'ils se posent et
électricité a commencé la plus durement
en tout cas nous vasselle a vécu c'était
bas taux moyen était de mon équipe donc
nous on était chez les rouges si les
rouges en avait pas de harpon donc pour
pêcher il y avait rien au niveau de la
nourriture on vous l'avez de temps en
temps tu es aurait réussi c'est à voir
du foot mais c'est tout ce qu'on avait
écrit on n'avait pas de riz n'est pas de
casseroles on n'avait rien du tout donc
vraiment ce koh lanta était vraiment
très très très éprouvant niveau niveau
nourriture c'était vraiment très très
dur et franchement que toi il est plus
flanché par rapport à
la nourriture s'était alors c'est
quelque chose de compréhensible fait il
n'ya pas lui il n'y a pas que lui parce
qu'il a dit qu'il en avait proposé aux
autres pourquoi dire que lui qui a été
ma vie
oui non mais bien sûr elle est 17 heures
elle est légitime comme question il
s'avère qu'on a décidé et on en a
beaucoup discuté de sanctionner la
personne qui avait organisé
en l'occurrence la venue des aliments et
pas ceux qui avaient partagé theora nous
a jamais dit n'a jamais dit avec qui il
avait partagé
en l'occurrence on en connaît en tout
cas ceux qui se sont déclarés et nous on
se dit voilà on va sanctionner celui qui
a organisé cette tricherie est pas ce qu
on partage et d'accès
c'est ce que vous pourriez pas aussi
sanctionner tout le monde ça faisait ça
aurait complètement
surtout sait enfin où on a on a eu en
l'occurrence le nom de de certains et
mais on ne sait pas si on n'avait pas
d'autre donc il ya un moment avec une
certitude on avait une certitude c'est
que theora s'était fait rapatrier de la
nourriture comme il l'a dit à mahdia ce
que tu on veut être sûrs d'avoir fait ça
non moi j'aime pas tout comme les y moi
tu vois là c'est c'est quelqu'un avec
qui j'ai ça enlèverait au personnage
qu'il est parce que terrasse est restée
moi c'est vraiment un grand aventurier
après il a fait une erreur et je pense
que n'importe qui d'entre nous aurait pu
la faire à ce moment-là parce que tout
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que après là
c'est imagé 1 mais on était sur cette
île là et en face lille d'en face
c'était la maison des parents très sains
ça veut dire que des fois il envoyait le
feu car il faisait en face et on le
voyait du sens faut-il débat voilà c'est
la maison nos parents ils sont là en
face alors tu vas y voyait ça n'est en
train de faire des boulettes limite vous
voulez voir ça mais on croire du tout
c'est pourquoi la décision de la
production que la production procédé
sinon bah en fait comme témoin l'a dit
mais je serai là non mais un témoin il
il assume totalement mais alors juste ya
plein de gens qui disaient pourquoi ils
n'ont pas sanctionné tous les candidats
qui ont bénéficié de cette nourriture
parce qu'ils y voient là il ya des gens
qui se sont inscrits voilà moi je vous
dis ce qui est dit sur les réseaux et
donc il c'est faux c'est parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a maintenant deux lits
bénéficie qui ont bénéficié de la
nourriture alors on sait on l'a dit
c'est vraiment enfin franchement et
c'est pour ça que c'est important que la
matière
ma compagne
c'est tellement un moment de privations
que c'est pas un petit bout d'aliments
qui changent le cours du jeu je ne sais
pas si toi tu peux expliquer ça c'est
pas parce que tu auras demain il a mangé
et que par exemple là au moment où ça
s'est passé ou tard a pu avoir la
nourriture le lendemain ils ont fait
l'épreuve de tir à l'arc vous pensez
vraiment pas ce qu'il a mangé par des
légumes et un spectre il va mieux viser